[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
bin sehr das wisst ihr schon und das ist
daniele rossi ja und denn daniele den
haben vielleicht einige schon auf
facebook entdeckt denn vor kurzem haben
wir schon eine richtig coole aktion
gemacht daniele ist ein freund von uns
aus hamburg und er ist der gründer von
trendlos dem aus kurz was dazu sagen na
klar natürlich brauchen wir seit zehn
jahren das ist eine online plattform für
neue lebensmittel vorstellen also ist es
nur auf den deutschen markt kommt und
wir möchten euch einfach gerne
inspirieren neues kennenzulernen neue
lieblingsprodukte zu entdecken und neue
produkte ausprobiert und eigentlich
haben wir auch vieles gemeinsam denn
murat und nicht wir haben auch die regel
beim einkauf immer ein lebensmittel
mitzunehmen was wir noch nicht kannten
also manchmal steckt so davon denken
lieber nicht und er sagt komm jetzt
probieren wir's weil wir uns nicht
probieren dann können wir auch nichts
neues entdecken und oftmals ist es echt
ne coole überraschung und bleibt uns
funktioniert genauso und da kann man
sich auch online auf der homepage die
sachen durchlesen neues entdecken und
einfach auch inspirieren lassen
genau und wer möchte kann sich auch gern
was nach hause schicken lassen danach
lockte die form einer box oder aber auch
und darum geht es hier heute in form
eines adventskalenders und wir haben ein
letztes mal schon challenge gemacht und
zwar habe ich da die cobox ausgepackt
und ich wusste nicht was drinsteckt und
habe für murat ein drei-gänge-menü
gemacht und es kam bei euch auch
ziemlich cool an
und jetzt haben wir uns gedacht machen
wir zusammen einen adventskalender im
sli style und er ist richtig schön solle
coole geschenkidee
und ich weiß noch nicht welche produkte
drinnen sind absolut überrascht er mich
ja auf jeden fall okay murat komme rein
erst schon ausgepackt also man muss
sagen es riesig und er ist schön also
nicht der murat sondern der kalender
aber du bist auch du kannst du heute
nicht riesig
und zwar geht es da 24 türchen und
hinter jedem türchen ist eine zutat also
lebensmittel und jetzt haben uns gedacht
machen wir heute auch eine challenge am
ende des videos gibt's übrigens ein
tolles gewinnspiel ihr könnt nämlich
fünf adventskalender hier auf diesem
kanal gewinnen und fünf adventskalender
auf dem brett
mal
[Musik]
auf facebook wurde ich schon gefragt
hätte was ist denn in dem kalender
drinnen also sally produkte sind nicht
drin denn bei mir gibt es ja an
lebensmitteln eigentlich nur wandel
extrakt das kennt ihr alle schon ist
nichts neues und 24 türchen mit vanille
extrakt gut ich würde mich darüber
freuen
aber wir wollen ja neue produkte das
heißt ich weiß selber auch nicht was
drin steckt da hat mich der daniele
überrascht und wir machen es jetzt
einfach gleich so murat ich hab die
zahlen von 1 bis 24
jetzt sieht man sich auch aufgeschrieben
er darf die zahlen ziehen und ich öffne
die türchen und wir machen jetzt nicht
alle 24 auch weil dann wäre der
überraschungseffekt auch weg wird sagen
also maximal zwölf bis 15
ok passt oder um den rest
da lassen wir uns wirken die solche zahl
und dann mache ich dann genau und der
daniela hat diesen kalender für uns
jetzt ganz extra gepackt also der
kalender der so gepackt ist ist bei euch
ein bisschen anders weil später einfach
sonst der überraschungseffekt weg wäre
das heißt wenn bei uns hier natürlich 1
1 lebensmittel ist steht kann das
lebensmittel später aber anders sein
jeder kalender gesicht das 24 türchen
also ich möchte ich an einem tag alle ja
das machst du immer bei der schokolade
ok darf ich sagen dass auf dem hocker
steht auch sehr schön zu dir
aufzuschauen komm wir starten jetzt
direkt und dann backe ich daraus etwas
das wohl und weh und ihr dass beide
probieren okay ich noch mal zulegen
ja komm wir liegen hier normal das ist
echt groß kann aber schön ins wohnzimmer
stellen oder in die küche
murat
also schauen was man so ja ich habe hier
alle drin hab ich die 124 und vergab
sehen also morath bereich passiert ist
ein glücksbringer weil ich nicht
erklären lassen
[Musik]
yeah und presse freunde
aha
peter löscher
es begann
[Musik]
vegan und bio zitronenschale von nicole
gärtner
[Musik]
sweet family kakaobutter zucker honig
die technik sogar verdient
was ist das
hh
[Musik]
oder marmelade sim lock
honig sein ich lieb' selbst in jeder
variation
[Musik]
project also den rest verraten wie
nichts sonst ist es ja keine
überraschung mehr ich glaube 15 produkte
damit lässt sich gut was backkartoffeln
ich glaube ich mache es mir einfacher
und ich mache einfach zwei sachen ok
macht oberst typisch ist irgendwas ist
okay mein herz mich sagen wie rote beete
protokoll wobei man damit mit sich ja
doch was süßes vattenfall mit roter bete
aber ich sollte jetzt schon ein bisschen
vielleicht in ruhe kuchen mit einem bus
mit einem schokoladenguss ob es herzhaft
formation zwei sachen ja vielleicht
wenig noch was dazu vielleicht ein
bisschen zitronen schon in dem dreieck
oder so honka mache ich hier mit rein
honig selber kann ich hier über
marmelade machen welche rein honig kann
man theoretisch je nachdem was wir
machen auch noch darüber kein bisschen
haben gegen thun glücksbringer kommt
wieder darin das mehl und den essig
entweder so oder ich packe
ok also noch etwas mir spontan jetzt
einfällt wäre entweder packe ich jetzt
aus roter beete und dem den freien mail
mit dem süßkartoffel mail ein baguette
so paket das make magic baguette ok und
macht dann irgendwie tipps dazu
oder wir machen sowas wie schon achtmal
for culture ok oder flammkuchen zum
beispiel war doch was
katja flammkuchen kann ich einfach dass
martins aus dem ofen
das ist kein narzissmus überlegt weil
ich fast nicht überlegt mir das jetzt
selber und durch die überraschend die
lass mich überraschen
also ok also was fällt mir spontan ich
meine ich nehme noch normale zutaten aus
dem kühlschrank und aus meiner
vorratsschrank dazu ich werde glaube ich
den rückrufen machen mit vanille
tonkabohne das ist die glasur der
kakaobutter zucker das mehl kann ich gut
benutzen ist 3300 aber es passt auch gut
dann mache ich noch ein paar gewürze mit
ryan lucas kann ich auch schmelzen und
mit in den teig geben und was ich schon
immer machen wollte ich glaube das mache
ich auch
ich hab mal gesehen sondern google hofft
mit einer cheesecake füllung vielleicht
kann ich ja einfach eine weihnachtskugel
luft machen
eine cheesecake füllung und kann damit
die blaubeeren mit äpfeln reinmachen
weiter betreiben und die packer nisse
als deko völlig the flag den probiere
ich erst mal und vielleicht ein bugrad
kriegst du okay und ich hole mir kurz
meine zutaten aus dem kühlschrank und
aus dem vorratsschrank und dann legen
wir direkt los mit dem ersten rezept und
jetzt gibt es einen weihnachtlichen
gugelhupf zuerst wenn ich jetzt im teig
herstellen für den teig verwende ich 100
gramm joghurt 250 gramm margarine 100
gramm braun und zucker und eine prise
salz 80 gramm honig ein päckchen tanker
zucker 4 eier diesem zimmer waren 350
gramm mehl 2 teelöffel backpulver 125
milliliter lauwarme milch und hier habe
ich noch die gewürze einen halben
teelöffel irgendwo und einen teelöffel
zimt und den fleck riegel
ich habe zehn top aufgestellt mit warmem
wasser und da werde ich jetzt genug
abschmelzen im wasserbad und den ofen
habe ich auch bereits vorgeheizt
[Applaus]
ich kann jetzt in der zwischenzeit schon
mal die margarine nehmen
die kann man ja direkt aus dem
kühlschrank benutzen weil sie so schön
streichfähig ist
[Musik]
dann gebe ich hier den tanker zucker
dazu das richtig zum nachtanken recht
gut da spart man sich auch das reiben
der tonkabohne dann gebe ich hier den
honig dazu so bekommen wir so ein
bisschen lebkuchen geschmack in salz und
brauner zucker und die zutaten werden
jetzt kurz war drei bis vier minuten
cremig verrührt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der flüssige nutzer kommt dann direkt
zur butter zucker honig mio und dann
kommen nacheinander die eier dazu
[Applaus]
jetzt wünsche ich noch das backpulver
mit dem mehl und den gewürzen
die zutaten werden dann auch in den teig
gesiebt und gemeinsam mit der lauwarme
milch eingerührt der rührteig ist jetzt
fertig und jetzt bereite ich noch die
cheesecake füllung zu für die
tankfüllung verwende ich zwei eier 500
gramm quark 80 gramm weiße schokolade
die mit nougat rist 30 gramm stärke und
16 gramm frische freunde apfelstückchen
mit blaubeeren die isle of wight christ
habe ich jetzt bereits über dem
wasserbad geschmolzen
und jetzt werden hier einfach alle
zutaten für die kiesfüllung verrührt
also quark mit rein
die eier stärke zum binden und auch die
schokolade und die schokolade sorgt hier
dafür dass das ganze süß genug wird die
hatte eine schöne leichte süße
wahrscheinlich nougat nicht zumal er
kann nach mogat passt als auch perfekt
zum rührteig und dann noch ein bisschen
chris boyce ich denke schon dass es ganz
gut schmeckt jetzt alles schön klümpchen
frei verrühren
[Musik]
ein bisschen zu kaffee und ich glaub ich
nehme einfach nur mal ein bisschen honig
mit rein und hier gebe ich noch diese
abflogen blaue stückchen rein so als
füllung
ich glaube das passt ganz gut vor allen
dingen hat man halt geige frege
trockenfrüchten immer den vorteil dass
sie nicht zermatschten weil eben keine
flüssigkeit drinnen halten lässt
das habe ich in der guglhupf form die
fertig mit etwas bakteriums bringen
[Applaus]
jetzt kommt her zwei drittel des tages
hinein
[Applaus]
dann so ein bisschen verstreichen und
wie so eine kleine mulde formen
[Applaus]
und da kommt die fdp skip füllung rhein
und die muss einfach schön vom teig
ummantelt werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und damit die kiesfüllung mit dem
restlichen teig abgedeckt
[Applaus]
hast du das vergessen der fleck kommt
hier jetzt noch obendrauf
hmm lecker schokolade als einfach auf
die oberfläche brüssel
so mehr fast nicht trauen das letzte
stück ist
mal gespannt wie der kuchen spenden wird
google oft ist schon fertig und ich habe
ihn als fünf minuten abkühlen lassen und
werden jetzt direkt aus der form raus
stützen er riecht schon sehr sehr lecker
und ich hoffe dass er genauso gut
schmeckt
[Musik]
kathrein weißen abdecken abkühlen lassen
und dann geht es mit der klasse weiter
jetzt nehme ich den kakaobutter zucker
da steht drauf dass man ihnen mit
lauwarmem wasser vermischt ich denke da
kann man auch ganz gut espresso oder zum
beispiel milch nehme gibt natürlich auch
noch einen anderen geschmack
ich habe jetzt hier schon die menge
abgefüllt ich mache das aber mit wasser
weil ich ja schon viel aroma im kuchen
drinnen habe jetzt einfach schön
verrühren
[Musik]
und da gibt ihr einfach nur so viel
wasser dazu so dass einfach kein
dickflüssiger guss entsteht da kommt
dann direkt auf die torte
[Musik]
da kommen jetzt auch die pks keiner oben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aus den übrigen zutaten mache ich jetzt
vor katja mit roter beete und käse ich
habe ich jetzt schon die zutaten für den
hefeteig für den hefeteig verwende ich
einen halben würfel hefe 250 milliliter
lauwarmes wasser einen esslöffel honig
250 gramm süßkartoffel mehl 250 gramm
weizenmehl die geriebene zitronenschale
olivenöl und salz
ich gebe zuerst einmal die hefe in eine
rührschüssel unser größter sie ein
bisschen
da kommt das wasser dazu dann ein
bisschen honig und da kann ich die
zutaten schon mal verrühren
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt mehr dazu und das
süßkartoffel male das sieht man auch
schon richtig toll an der farbe und es
riecht hat wirklich nach süßkartoffeln
also wenn ihr süß kartoffelchips schon
mal gegessen habe genauso lecker riecht
auch das mehl und hat auch eine tolle
farbe und das schmeckt sogar leicht
süßlich dann salz dazu ich denke hier
passt auch ganz gut die zitronenschale
eine kleine prise und olivenöl
jetzt kann ich aus den zutaten einen
schönen geschmeidigen teig kneten
[Musik]
das merke dass datei gibt es ein
bisschen trocken ist also gebe ich da
noch ein bisschen wasser dazu denken
einfach die anderen eigenschaften von
süßkartoffeln jetzt ist der teig schön
geschmeidig und ich kann ihnen jetzt zu
einer kugel formen und dann mit öl
bestreichen abdecken und für eine stunde
aufgehen lassen
jetzt der teig richtig schön aufgegangen
und ich kann jetzt die focaccia zu
bereiten ich habe mir zu billig ich mach
zwei verschiedene varianten eine
variante mit roter beete und käse und
eine süße variante mit der marmelade für
die focaccia verwende ich drei esslöffel
olivenöl 100 gramm saure sahne etwas
salz und pfeffer ich habe ich den honig
senf die rote beete 200 gramm weichkäse
thymian getrocknet und für die süße
variante nehme ich auch nochmal saure
sahne tonka zucker und die marmelade
ich schaue jetzt erst mal den teig aus
hinter hat eine richtig tolle farbe
würde mich interessieren ob das süßlich
schmeckenden süßkartoffel
[Musik]
aber ich finde geschmack recht gut und
die konsistenz ist ein bisschen anders
als bei normalem er hat ja auch jetzt
nicht die backeigenschaften wie normales
aber es ist echt richtig gut vor allem
die farbe ist super ich bin gespannt wie
sie hoch an schmeckt habe ich den teig
geviertelt macht einfach viel stück und
rolle dass jetzt schön dünn aus
dann einfach direkt auf ein blech leben
sie müssen brauche ich ja unsere ja was
ist das jetzt dieses spezielle spezielle
mail
das ist doch mal gespannt wie schmeckt
mir kenne ich aber was ist das denn ich
habe ja nie was wirklich ist und ich war
jetzt sicher dass die meisten der leute
noch probiert haben damit sichern wir
können euch behauptet schreibt sich die
kommentare wer hat von euch schon mal
süßkartoffeln mehr probleme die ganze
stadt studiert machen und zwar jetzt
einfach ein bisschen olivenöl leben und
die teige damit bestreichen war das auch
in der box in olivenöl
nein aber das leder zu hause ja ok frag
mich jetzt bei jedem produkt ob es an
der box war für mir leid ich nehme jetzt
hier die saure sahne wird die mit salz
und pfeffer
da kommt jetzt der honig senf dazu also
ich denke ich dass es passt somit mit
süßkartoffeln gebacken war es noch nie
gemacht und du denkst spannend so erhält
man gespannt ob es geschmeckt aber ich
würde gerne mal den honig sind ja genau
das wollte ich mich probieren jetzt
musst du probieren sonst weiß ich nicht
ob es passt ja was noch nicht mal
probierten denken schrenk doch es passt
damit um ihren dazu ich musste senf ich
weiß ja um die sich ersuchen senfter das
gemüse legen und süßlich und diesen satz
gut ne ja manches auch abspecken
verkaufst du mir ich mir dann gleich
noch nie kommen das zeuge zusammen zu
machen alles
dann konnte ich koch für dich da kommt
das erzählt direkt auf den teig der soße
mischung aus flammkuchen und macho dann
gebieten noch neuen namen das log hat ja
dann kommen ja blog hat ja genau die
hälfte kommt verteilt diesmal also dass
die menge reicht meine nein wäre doch
was
das muss erst vorteil ach so und ich
kann jetzt hier noch die rote beete
abgießen
wieso konnten wir nun kommt er manchmal
kommen sie doch einfach einen schritt
weiter nach rechts immer gespannt
naturwissenschaft gewürfelt
und schmeckt wie rote beete jetzt nimmst
du das einfach und das coole ich dass
ich nicht so lag es also nicht so weiß
schon noch schön bissfest dieses fest
ist sport das mag ich das jetzt hier
darauf verteilt ok dann kommt da noch
der weichkäse darüber gleich noch was
drauf mach mal ehrlich wieso ist krank
zu hause
ich habe es einfach gestürzt das macht
es möglich
ich mach das jetzt alleine fertig
[Musik]
jetzt ist die süße variante strand dafür
nehme ich jetzt wieder die saure sahne
dann ein päckchen zucker
das werde jetzt hier für mich
[Musik]
jetzt ja auch direkt auf den teig
streichen und dann kommt jetzt da die
marmelade drauf und da nehme ich jetzt
die schwarz kirche holunderblüte
marmelade von simmler einfach so in
sachsen drauf
nehme ich mir eine gabel und verteilen
ist ein bisschen
[Musik]
und ab in den backofen
jetzt kommen wir zum gewinnspiel und zu
gewinnen gibt es fünf adventskalender
wenn ihr folgende frage richtig
beantwortet und zwar wie lange üblich
schon great news genau schreibt einfach
in die kommentare
das gleiche gewinnspiel gibt es übrigens
auch auf dem grand news kanal frage
jetzt nämlich auch fünf kalender zu
gewinnen und dann werdet ihr die
nachricht nicht für uns und bekommt den
zucker steckt genauigkeit bei facebook
sind bei instagram mitmachen und ihr
könnt bei youtube waren okay also noch
mal wie lange er gibt schon breaking
news wie viele berater darf probiert
jetzt willst du es ja doch flokati oder
da ich weiß nicht genau eigentlich ein
ramschladen makatsch ein zwischenspiel
doch musste auch morgen ich habe doch
ein bisschen abkühlen lassen aber und
passt trotzdem auf ok ich gucke mal den
part ohne belag drohte mir anders da
schmeckt ja ganz anderes aber anders und
schlecht jetzt und vor allem bekommt der
teig durch das süßkartoffeln unten so
eine kruste
wieso karamellisiert wow schmeckt echt
gut
unser kers ein passwort für uns auch
richtig brötchen nicht vorstellen wie
das gehen
sie ist kartoffel süßkartoffeln sie
empfehlen echt cool wirklich accra vater
lass uns nach variante aus aber hier
muss jetzt aufpassen weil die marmelade
bestimmt was ist aus dem fall raten sich
also ruhig mal dran
franck hat sogar und dann ja mal ganz
ehrlich als technologisch katar coni
herausfinden dass die pizza krankheit
wenn ich ihn hat entscheidet sich erst
ganz allmählich über das mehl marmelade
auch marmelade soundmäßig leichter
richtig lecker schmeckt muss ehrlich
sagen ich bin begeistert von dem mail
bereit für ein kuchen
was dann noch einen kuchen der google ja
aber echt begeistert wir haben es noch
ein stückchen und dann gibt es gleich
kuchenverkauf schon mal gespannt wann
die pkw beim backen schon drauf oder
oder auszuspielen aufnehmen später weil
ich habe da auch die kuchen klasse drauf
und wir diesen kakaobutter zucker aber
gespannt
er riecht jedenfalls ich mag es wenn ich
sehe es aber schon mich an der küste war
die kritik vieler kunden und damit in
der mitte mit diesen gefriergetrocknete
wäre ich mal gespannt
ist auch hatte ich mag ja sein
bosch mit richtig dass nicht nur
unterricht sofa wo sie gleich deiner
maße kompromiss gelungen wäre erst mal
eine richtig coole leute gemacht es
nachts mal ohne mich wäre ganz ganz
ehrlich gewesen wenn wir jetzt was nicht
geschmeckt hat dich ganz ganz normal was
sie mal war es nicht schmeckt das sind
vielleicht mal ein produkt nicht
schmeckt oder so ist feedback ist das
ist wohl in ordnung
man muss es sagen machst du dann macht
das ist richtig cool war ganz weiß nicht
genau was mich freuen noch eingefallen
ist beim vor katja oder rahmen kuchen
oder wie auch immer da war noch
zitronenschale im teig und bei dem ein
stück habe ich dir voll gut gemerkt wie
gut ich weiß nicht welches auto man das
hier ist aber die kombination also alle
mit schneller lieferung ist komisch und
da und nahmen auch den kampf und das
bullishe die füllung ist nicht zu viel
also macht die führung nicht größer als
hier wirklich nicht geht auch
produktionsbedingt einfach so ein
leckerer saft gibt es kuchen ich jetzt
nicht hier kriegt ausgemacht die
zauberei und ich hab ja auch andere
dinge mehr helfen aber er war schon ein
bisschen zu erheblichen der ja dann hab
ich dich da raus geschmissen so ist mir
leid
jedenfalls habe ich heute sehr viel
neues kennen gelernt unter anderem
süßkartoffeln tomkat sogar viele weitere
zutaten die echt richtig mein favorit
muss ich ehrlich sagen war natürlich das
ding der teig das mehl ist das war eine
rote beete kohl weil ich mir die hände
nicht dass man dann waren nicht die
moral aus baden württemberger hat lieber
auf seine musik feiert natürlich kann
man hier auch gut dazu essen wir aber
auf dem cover was ja auch gut jedenfalls
der selber auch tun
ja das war auch sehr wach zwar alles
kommen jedenfalls hoffe ich dass ich
dieses video gefallen hat habe ich die
challenge gemeistert und werden zum teil
entsprochen
ich mache jetzt mal mit challandes genau
richtig
und bist du was ihr könnt ja mal
schreiben was er aus diesen zutaten
gemacht hat einfach in die kommentare
falls etwas einfällt wie häufig das
gefühl wirklich viel coolere genau weil
das war das erste was mir zu auf die
schnelle eingefangen ist aber vielleicht
kommt er auf noch bessere denn also viel
spaß beim nachmachen man bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss und schreibt wieder
die kommentare bin ich nächste mal was
machen sie sehr lustig
[Musik]
einfach sally ist die timeline freundin
sabine und ich wir hatten richtig
schönes mittels wochenende in
großbritannien da gab es richtig tolle
köstlichkeiten ich möchte die
urlaubsgefühle wieder zurück banken um
ihre freundin zu überraschen mag sally
buch very british eine königliche thate
und gebäck bei der brücke steht dafür
muss ich tatsächlich wie so eine einfach
sally sonntag 16 uhr bei vox